OK Google
He told his wife that we'll talk about it
and she's like happy like there's a dinner
and she's like we'll talk
So then they're in the room and he said
he'll they'll talk to like a therapist right
She's
It's
I'll be outside
Want to see if they end up putting each
other's AI against each other and how that
works outMaybe you should have to fight her
yet.
In the show it might be
Ready
Just because they want toMake it funny.
MichiganNew York. Ohio silent.
Tokyo California
But I'm definitely going to visit a lot of
States cuz like I want to go around the
world
But if I want to Regal to one that I already
been to I'm about to do that likeCuz I want
to go to Dubai.
I want to go to fishThat's wrong. I want to
see bye.
Are you agent 7 killing me
I'm 14 come on forCome on for it don't do
it.
Yeah yeah
Okay okay now somebody has to pass the
gasSomebody has to pass the gas who's going
to pass it.
Somebody has to pass it come onOnly takes
one number two is out.
Okay
Cuz you know I didn't get home until Friday
until I didn't get home on Friday until 2:00
in the morning
Then I had to be at U of H at 6:30 I mean
and I had to be up there but not the house
at 6:00
And then after I left from us I went
straight to ChicagoAnd then get home to then
walk out the door till 3:00 a.m..
Then I got to get off today around 1:00 just
to be at the elections at 6:00
But at least money will be tightWe don't
have to worry about moving with me well
unless you want me. But.
I'm so sorry they don't charge me $1,000 in
the morningEverything let them know.
Bye my results are not
So I need to let me back to I'm thinking
anything
Paid payment still going to be doing the
15th even though I got them to move it to a
different date not going to tell you what
could tear that day because it does not
matter
The goal is that they'll pay me before it's
actually
And never just playing Round Rock so I'm
still be doing the 15th
You know what I'm saying okay I thought them
the same thing so other than that still
stack your bread up stuff
I really need that thing taken off I'm tired
of the car stopping on me while I'm driving
Cuz you go to a
And it sucks to it's going to bring me back
to zero but I don't expect you and I have no
money to be able to come up with that right
now especially
Luckily I have itYou know.
Are we trying to remember I told you we
trying to come up with some shit me and my
server trying to come up with some shit for
the bar
Will not for the bar but for bar one you
know what I'm saying for us so that we can
eat
I'm sorry we played Raiders today
I'm sorry I got a particular customer to
come in with a shirt that's custom made with
the Raiders on it this act like Daddy bro
when I see her tattoo
When I sit here and tell you this had on and
came in on Wednesday hoping he seeing you
brother this stood in the window with his
Raiders jersey doing this
I say soon as he walked in the dark thing
you said
Yeah I got to be at the hospital so if I get
there before 5:00 then
I didn't play Sims last night I also got
inside
Oh Lord in our head or our old Head bar
accidents on one before me the reason why
they put me on one you can't even fuck that
She ain't no dumb motherfucker so I can tell
her that cuz she see how I was trying to
clock itI'll try to clock out.
Don't smile I'm like you want one you can
have one that's your shit I want itIt's.
I see what you doing I'm right now I'm
really tired of when April keeps you busy
It's like I don't want one and I'm not sure
if I'm back for good and if you I'm like
well what about Wednesday you can have
Wednesdays I'll do every other one to see if
I say I work with that
But she has no intentions of being a
headboard
Crazy
Well I heard customers came back oh my God
I was so nervous for yesterday
So I'm like literally when people came in
they said you people usually come to me they
would look past me like
SomethingBut then one person made me feel
good.
He said cuz they were supposed to work my
way up to being able to keep being them but
they're going to answer me but anyway he was
like our girl was back but but but we
completed a chance we like you
We like you we want to be a part of our
family you part of the clear you part of the
group or you come and we going to keep
coming to you I was like holy shit
Hallelujah?
??
Got to close open yesterday on Friday Friday